are we going okay start over but not
really because everybody heard it
already go I don't know what you
remember I'm out of here man low for a
couple of days I'll call Joe and know
what the [ __ ] this guy did or what he
[ __ ] it there see how the [ __ ] shame
I really thought he was [ __ ] damn her
[ __ ] sure well we can't take this
[ __ ] hospital F with him for
sure again your dearest [ __ ] put him
out alright do it every two trusts job
but how we're gonna get a hold of Joe
I mean he's supposed to be here but he's
not when she making me very [ __ ]
nervous about [ __ ] being here I mean
this guy [ __ ] applaud our [ __ ]
Robert now we got dead cops there Robert
Jesus Christ I mean
[Laughter]
what's up fool we were watching them
which one huh yeah that's a great movie
then we were brought up I'm dealing to
that for you to do a chocolate positive
person Asian Wow but oh that's our
brother his sister Charlie Bronson he'll
put up a little wig roller here like a
little picture like Pippi Longstocking
goes back there he'll be like this hey
they don't put on the beanie to blow
over the baby over the thread size
broadly under 500 look as a box full
sure to Lisa
Esparza it's hard to find them maybe the
size well they don't make it anymore
that's an old print that's like the
first print I think that's the Spooner
rate is Spooner what is it
rain Spooner something like that yeah
rain Spooner re yn Spooner what's awful
my fat ass last night trying to work out
that ass on and everything came over
here bro sup bro sup [ __ ] you know my
friends didn't even tell you they were
being a bro just ain't no see oh just
[ __ ] it to the top like a time to change
always Barbie up I take oh yeah
no I Hotel being a bubbler they're being
it always scavenge Ebro like I wanna
find out the healthy like just buzzer it
over here I know I know that I'm moving
I'm older I know later right this was
your he might think that they might they
might shut down food right now right no
food is gonna come your honor either I
have a show tonight is gonna be food
there I'll get to an hour early bro you
know what brought the shuttle touch of
10 plating
right I would ever play bro are charging
me bro
[Music]
Connor coins and he wanted to go pay
let's just wait wow that will be like
this I cover I'm a para by tomorrow boy
at the restaurant
Wow get there bro everybody's to check
he [ __ ] he gets a free meal because
you know they're you talking about that
fish spot the deep fried Oh take us to
eat for free and he didn't pay very good
many times many times many times so you
don't love Lynn of Alaska choice oh yeah
yeah you know denim denim in the past
good guy shows you do leather look like
Visalia they're portable portable I know
the the Merced theater and then Visalia
show like the Fox or yeah that little
two-day run that were said when I did it
what time before like I one last comment
Ali and I remember that up that food
eating steak bro ready for the theater
a little lounge he's eating good good
cuts [ __ ] green room no food marbled
steak flies are pests we don't bro for a
meal
yo Matt we'll get a meal it's gonna be
on the show a little bit Felipe you know
that peach money waddle guy who fly fly
fly so peachy by a team a [ __ ] party
hey pretty boy pretty boy come here word
is bad news writer for they welcome
Minzy welcome to Merced welcome to all
the Central Valley
you didn't say reading or oh I'm from
Modesto California
well I guess I do yeah she's [ __ ] she's
from there when when I moved out here I
had never never met her you started with
I started Modesto Modesto and then I
would do shows in Sacramento in San
Francisco but when I met you is when you
came to Modesto
or maybe I came out here how did you
start Modesto you started before
Marcella started yes I was sent to Syria
by Lena she grew up in East LA bro she
took gangbanger over there under [ __ ]
F by the by the GM bro how about Jim she
didn't really gangbang but she backed
him up oh it's got to be about dinner
one of those cholos blue leg like once
you get ready for the fight should put
like razor blades in right here when you
grab it bro you did thank you you know
her for sure or you're just guessing she
wasn't like one of those girls I would
do that no she was on the bench she was
coming off the bench profiling that's
what was their crime
[Music]
[Laughter]
Toby gets buzz we find out a new
celebrity he'll have to [ __ ] her
they taught Tina feel do the interview
all y'all man Tina fight it won't [ __ ]
what does she have to say about that
[Laughter]
like people try to give you the product
like you know you recently merch
yeah but this way I don't teacher to
give you right now here man
I want you to wear my t-shirt or you
take your folder with them and they give
you a t-shirt you know it's what you
holding it up and you're like this now
you're promoting their t-shirt man it
somebody give me a t-shirt if it's ugly
that's what I shoulda trash but after
each other around
Ravager I give it to the gutter cleaning
the theater bro yeah so Toby sure that
somebody gave him drinkware oh my god
the tip of this shirt had a can opener
like sewn into fabulous
[Laughter]
24/7 the dryer be popping them and
everything one [ __ ] shirt just [ __ ]
second a clack clack clack brother
[ __ ] drive I can drive by dryer it's
gonna be this way wood right in his
bright brightest red t-shirt I think the
brass garnet wow Cornhusker bright it
was ugly bad lately these t-shirts that
people give out at least people these
t-shirts people make they just have like
one word on it or a stupid phrase it
doesn't mean anything and they think
it's like a great design it's not like
you will keep a shirt like ill kids
where they make great designs or what
was that it's a fight like they make
great shirts that have something cool
some great design on it but just to have
a word on there that's like in a script
or in some sort of like block lettering
or whatever I think I really I think one
of the somebody gave me some wack-ass
wine shirt called nebula in Portland and
he's like hey man please promote this
and I was just like dude nebula really
give you a motivator I think that was
one of the weirdest wackiest shirt yeah
a drink where is a drink where
[Laughter]
they fell asleep no no I have it
okay no it's actually than the other guy
ticky ticky - what voice is the rock
monster guy yeah
it's like a mockumentary of vampires
okay you know the wolves bro oh yeah oh
that's [ __ ] funny where they come from
o to a Salem's
Tony hates pizza Wow what's up fool
anybody looking for a show to watch
owpain 15 he just so he just told me
that about that show I just started
watching a crashing not bad not bad on
HBO yeah I'm on season season 1 episode
6 crashing all right people don't snort
powder I've done cold book I don't know
what the I don't think you ever started
injecting it what's up we'll see your
Grand Junction March 23rd I got four
tickets for me and my family about 40
years old all right okay the four people
there for RSVP that's good come on lucky
nice about the show you know I want a
big for a little bit I don't want that
either
I don't you know it's tough to make that
decision
turn to the chairs right away take a
chance take a chance on this guy so
let's build the sky before I knew that
before I knew that
[Laughter]
yeah I said I want we'd only write about
that do [ __ ]
so we get the empty bro hello me you and
Joe Diaz right as Obama baby or whoever
and land up when a food kick out the
checks and [ __ ] he took all that did lay
off man we'll give you this guarantee
dog with that guy stays but still man
you know nice try Comic Standing
if they send the minion to [ __ ] knock
it down yeah like this you had a
contract he gave a 50% deposit ahead of
it he gave 50% to the agency ahead of
time word where they're pulled back the
other 50 comes when you perform and
services we don't I would go with a card
saying but even do they add extra [ __ ]
when I get there
Yeah right I did the show bro visalia
bro they had a Budweiser truck they were
selling beer outside I saw Clydesdale
they for free yeah so the interns intern
bartender don't have the money to the
show ain't that a [ __ ] still padding
down hey but I'm not lawyers no more I
don't know boy if I write the if I'm
ready that rising as a comedian and
you've been promoting since before ever
know the number biker you should have
rode the promoter yeah no you should
always have the money in there yeah no
matter what
yeah we're talking everybody but you
know like you just gonna have the money
they're mad
promoter so he can't be that the guy
from gay bro and [ __ ] no [ __ ] fire
fester do about doors
whoever yeah right you stepped up you
wrote the contract honor that
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was a road gig and
it was the deposit was was given and
then the rest wasn't at the show yeah no
it was a decent crowd but yet you know
you were hearing excuses from the
promoter and blah blah blah and then
just didn't get money and I waited or I
waited and waited
Modesto know it was in Sacramento it was
in Sacramento it was a big show actually
Stockwell no no [ __ ] he's a comic we
know DC I forgot I forgot his name but
he was he was shady he was shady and it
was a big show who's me Paul
Carlos was on the show I mean it was a
bunch of us we did Arco Arena
we got half up front and then and the
other half just wasn't given and Paul
got a girl at the a at the end he took
care me but I'm like you just took care
of me that day but it was it was a
[ __ ] ass State Theater back goober
asked you about war yeah we did with war
yeah it were it was in Cisco San
Francisco and she was filled with all
that yeah yeah that was these cables
over but that was there you you did you
did you didn't get filmed so that's cool
your DVD they never came all the other
good Phil no
was gilbert in the show Cooper's on the
show but he he said no he said no so he
didn't get filmed either that guy was
cool though he took big cash that's the
dude that's the guy that ripped me off
that's the guy that's the do it buttered
you up with this so I did another show
with him yeah so we did a big-ass show
that guy yeah yeah no he was cool but
not this time that this one time when he
didn't pay then that was the end of that
but yeah you can only I've been doing
comm for almost over 20 years I've only
been ripped off four times but you
[ __ ] remember oh that's it it's not a
best pretty good ratio being don't come
for 20 years and not get paid four times
it's a big slap in the face you know you
you're being advertised you know I'm not
saying I'm a big comic but you being
advertised people are coming to see you
know a variety of comedians and you just
don't get money it's a [ __ ]
that's like the biggest the biggest just
just the boy says it all it's hilarious
but I remember you when you still
commonly used to come to Modesto and you
would do shows at the State Theatre
those are fun shows oh yeah no no that
was a different that was a Louis we did
that one night that the [ __ ] road to
rule came in but okay that play on game
in the winter it was a tough that you
didn't uh camera yeah yeah Patriots when
the Patriots won 2001 yeah Wow and I
remember that show because Joe Diaz
thought they got your coke but it was a
big headline of speed ooh
and I forward to go buy some fried
chicken and the [ __ ]
at the gas station rank and watch you
talk about a double feature to look back
at music boom hit that [ __ ] fried
chicken brother the fro that one the
party one I thought wow survival tactics
came with a biscuit ball frozen kickin
Prince vegan dead [ __ ] the lady from
Star Wars vegan dead who's next
you weren't giving guns to Allah we
recovered a duel back in the day what's
up Larry so [ __ ] wrong here come the
jabs [ __ ] the [ __ ] jab so he was
lower you were [ __ ] Hardy right is
that we're gonna do now no [ __ ]
jugular thank you here it is the south
talking [ __ ] to the north
okay here we go no here we go and it
started comedy he would take me on the
road but I don't know about a [ __ ]
comedy he would take me on the road a
lot yeah he no nothing like it wasn't
[ __ ] Lauren hardy or anything like
that we were [ __ ] heckle and Jeckle
either anyway damn you ain't old school
you're going crates on were you digging
in the crates digging in these records
hilarious comedy bit they were like yes
no now that that was Brian and that was
a Martin Martin King and and and I
forgot he had another friend rolling
oldies no in marking the town Motown and
more what
there you go back to dry showing rivers
on the black no no no he lives he lives
in ie row more a great man short of know
where he's gonna go turning more now can
we get some flower motel him over the
[ __ ] boats anymore is a man I can't
nobody singing man
and they weren't will they say they
weren't somebody singing bro my little
eyes missing please put out like CD and
he lives in the whole act it was eight
minutes when it was a strong eighty even
Jade even J Lamont's like [ __ ] these
guys are good do even take the mom was
impressed critical that do that then the
latino guy will kill I got a bicycle
yeah yeah you guys know man god damn it
that was not me I know Larry Modesto and
more stop hating on the 209 yeah he
started way before me too right
I think in the early 90s and he's from
he's from Oakland and yeah but you do
open mic oh there was no open mics man I
would just go to bars and then showcases
were like in San Francisco like the
punch line in San Francisco were
sacramental that was it we need and we
didn't have really open mics back then
only the first TV credit be et and 98
and 99 I did be easy Gary Gary Owen was
hosting here at the Normandy casino and
then I did 99 when Lester Barrie was
hosting that [ __ ] you know you fried it
you know how long it take for you to go
on all day all day it was like your call
time was like 8:00 you going like a
[ __ ] 9:00 or 10:00 in the evening I
don't know why they wanted you all day
there but it's just that was how it was
but they're low time I'm thinking about
BT could just save money and have people
show up when you put on the boat to go
up instead of having all these trailers
all you swap trailers trailer for every
individual comedian everybody
trailer and funny that we do that like
what's the most urban show because when
I did that Kevin Hart show the other one
I have a whole limo no you did what
laughs Appaloosa no I did this one
Mike's
air was one the other one they had a
barber right that a bar case anyone get
faded up no you need to if we need to
leave weed around one block in his
[ __ ] limo everyone I'll go into that
show I was at my beach cooler bro they
have no car claria crack-tip mm-hmm and
I'm riding my bicycle and I see Eric are
you waiting for the bus he's gonna stain
show Wow yeah we were like I mean a guy
named Bob he smoked me on you from New
York his name is um hot tub hot tub
Wow no no he was in Lewis like you know
they were they were hot sauce hot sauce
hot sauce
kameena yeah it was a lot hotter than
your life so he would be he was like
that shucky ducky or Chucky shucky ducky
but just he would just say hot sauce all
time yeah Blackfoot name smoke smoke Wow
he didn't have smoke it was the hotel
he'll tell you about the badass gig
brother he did end up in the Bahamas
didn't wanna go back didn't want to come
back to Queens oh they were beautiful
women drinking they treated me like a
king but the people orders damn bro once
you stay there forever you no longer a
king it be the present holy [ __ ] tell
you about Aloha from one
[Laughter]
Wow I don't know how the other party the
other guy bro
who not looking but if I will politely
like [ __ ] now when new bid is
making out with a landlord lady
captain smooth over here wanted to hook
up with Joey Medina so bad that you
ended up in bed with everybody that
fooling to white candles in the car a
were driving and they'll play music they
don't talk about what the news is about
knows about these guys I'll save my
questions for lose wow dude Rubick it
down wow I just wanted to get with the
joy Medina because that was packing
that's the don't push it to a chick
[Laughter]
you're just one time but we actually get
along just thanks he said hey bro I say
forever doing my set don't do it anymore
that's it I said wherever one time and
he's off he called me and he's a haber
world
he called me no syllables dawg I just
let you know I say forever so don't say
forever I was like are you serious right
now
grandma bought that word fries on
Webster Wow look man I've been on the
that he started name dropping I've been
it's a nice job love that show yeah I've
heard that joke
and don't say forever I'm like okay I
guess it was no big deal
context forever I wasn't worried forever
like during a joke or whatever and he
caught wind of it I guess and this is
before before Internet and you know he's
so he called me my word that's weird
yeah but we actually did a show not that
long ago and I'll pass oh and he it was
great to see him you know we we read we
did some casino show Misha Vogel and
Willy it was fun show
well Willy's gig yeah was Willy's good
yeah
yeah and he it was a good time and he
was actually very nice super a behavior
actually great behavior and it's been
been a while since I seen him but he was
really cool man
want to capture little Wow see I never
gotten any Willie stories like that I
got the famous no I never got a little
walking or the karate kick I always
heard those stories from other community
a man good show BAM you know never I
never got you know wrestled dog yeah
wrestle dog well here comes Bam and I
never got the damn year none of that
[ __ ] you know I hear all the stories but
so will you Jackie Jackie bro so no I
yeah but I respected Dodgers I will [ __ ]
you how to pain you right yeah Fresno
okay no not all I respect the Dodgers
but I'm a Mets fan but I woke up here's
ago in the Mets beat the the Dodgers in
the playoffs I was there for like two
the ones that custody 2015 remember I've
never seen the Mets play Dodgers me
neither
now we forgot about it was only 2015
it's playoffs yes it's the Mets of the
play the Dodgers in the first round well
that's why can we beat the Braves they
would love to play the meds and they had
their picture with a long hair right
yeah Thor says Thor and Doubront yeah so
we go to that playoff game yeah I'm sure
you do that was before the money but am
i but I look in your timeline on your
Instagram I'm sure I look back you
always end up getting Colorado round up
games I hate them
these are these were the playoffs oh you
were there stop fronting you're good you
were there it's okay you're in denial
it's all right you were there who the
who's the med center fielder it was
Cespedes at the time you're trying to
think of who you're talking [ __ ] to yeah
somebody [ __ ] Doris Doris no you were
talking [ __ ] to Granderson Curtis
Granderson cuz he was he was playing in
left field that year no somebody else
man without without age here the weird
last name we looked up his wife holiday
it was holiday holiday never play for
the Mets man holiday you never play for
the meadow somebody that we looked up
and we find out who the wife Christian
Christian music who wife does not
mention to make it to the world
well the Mets went to the Roasters last
year then they got handled by the Royals
they here and yes we had a great great
team so yeah but Daniel Murphy was
killing it through all the play he
destroyed the Dodgers and everybody else
and then when he got to the World Series
they did they did they were they were in
a one-game playoff and they lost against
the Giants and then we haven't been back
since but that's still my team I still
like the Raiders like you it's been a
hard year it was a hard year hard years
hard year many have you guys been to the
stadium Mets Stadium I've never been I
I'd want I want to go to City field
that'd be great but I'm more I'm more
into football football and football
baseball or my thing I like football a
lot this was the first year I didn't go
to a Raider game it was kind of hard
oh man this is the first I did go to
Raider this is your first time drop so
what'd you think about the experience it
was awesome
I like I'm not really into football but
I love Raider fans because they're into
I know you don't like [ __ ] me which
is cool nothing wrong being a vegan but
what do you like I like wine in painting
curly you should know you should know
what I like what what I like Star Wars
remember I like Star Wars Star Wars toys
[Laughter]
it's collecting don't got [ __ ] on mine
everyone has someone has a great
collection but nothing like mine really
I've never seen yeah
so he sold a lot of he sold a lot of
stuff but he got Marvel kids they have
other cool toy boat they have no
brothers when you have a brother you
have that that Darth Vader hold carrying
case boy Dino had that [ __ ] no he
distorted everything he had Return of
the Jedi
mm-hmm but third one for me
but when he's 20s in the frozen tundra
sorry so when he goes there and then
that abominable snowman thing they had
this little diecast set and it was a
little cave and Luke can hang upside
down a little diecast Luke can hang
upside down and you can clip his legs
inside the little cave and then there's
a little abominable snowman it was no
different but there was a toy of the
tonton where he had a hatch that he
could go in there but I think back about
all the great we had a well not anymore
I'm good thank you
I used to here we go bring it on did a
big [ __ ] Scott still broke that's
right me you enjoy dealing with lawyers
no no you weren't but you're drinking I
was drinking and you're on Manny
motherfu told me you know somebody about
taking pills
Rivlin sorry just annoying on purpose I
was like that is a compliment and a dis
at the same time but it was we're on
Ritalin and you were annoying the the
the ritalin wasn't doing his job
but if you weren't on ritalin something
like that but I'm okay now I'm good
who don't take you no more no no I
yellow self-diagnosis and I haven't been
taking it for like a lot
[Laughter]
you think that's what's happened in your
body I think so I think that Bush
Escobar's bro he's avocado help taking
the medication it did and did it at some
times it [ __ ] me too yeah it would
have like weight gain
sometime I couldn't sleep sleep my sleep
pattern was always messed up I'd only
sleep for like I don't know like four
maybe four hours sometimes ADHD if you
have ADHD then Ritalin will have the
opposite effect but if you took it and
you don't have it it would mean it would
be scary I mean it was but so his body
is giving him the reaction from the
speed but it's helping his ADHD you know
what I mean like it's like it's helping
that but the side effect is affecting
his actual body of sleep patterns and
all that stay no your wife does a little
google searching here we go with the
[Music]
[ __ ] comedy do or 20 minutes ago I
was part of Motown and no I was I was a
guest panelist the topic was about
racism and stereotypes whatever so
people could finally bro man I don't
even remember
[Music]
about like a badass Forrest Gump a pop
Paul Mooney was on that show I barely
got a couple words in but it was it was
a you know [ __ ] me annoyed it raised
the stereotypes and they just wanted a
Latino point of view but it's great to
be on the spot guys this is like a
[ __ ] this is like the new TV credit
actually be on with you
hell yeah I thought I was gonna get this
before I got more people would have done
it with you instead of being the only
like people there was a couple other
ones too they blew it was it was great
it was one of the funnest your friends
huh it was it was like a Superbowl for
comedians it's really oh yeah it was
really fun no I did um I did I tape for
the Kevin Hart lol better that was great
and then I did a couple other shows
while I was out there so it was really
fun I was at for like 3 days when [ __ ]
your fluffy told me went to Montreal
story were nasty bro he said watch a
straight bar and heel pain is cheap to
know these two girls dancing front over
here in front of a table they get down
at that you know I've been the strip
club in Toronto dog and it's off the
[ __ ] hook they do it whatever in LA
New York do whatever they're fully nude
I don't know about they do whatever are
you points right that's what guys gotta
tell you
[Laughter]
no idea that was the whole time we were
just partying at the [ __ ] the hotel
at beer after party coconut [ __ ] in
the club they got put on a table and I
was getting really like like I was gonna
be first right and then like I just
[ __ ] with his cigarette and rolled it
on a coke and lit it up and I put my
head on to people afterwards so I get
some we smoked it right there Brule
they pass through me bro who wants a
weekend spree boy they were all speaking
French now they're part of us say what
is it for the leave yeah it was voted
yeah he's there in my way you know way
to the down there every year he's stable
he's you know Maas you know everybody
funny about that
[ __ ]
and watch real mm-hmm editor being the
only one that didn't want to be too
ethnic but they can't find and process
in the making of some bro they got
Italians consider each the head of they
had up Sebastian by the contour that
[ __ ] because it much wrong yeah when's
the last time you know that you've
turned down but they only offer the
ethnic show and we've turned it down
three times yeah you got you gotta have
you get you're ready for your gala I
mean you would destroy this 2005
that's where no friend of the condoms
got a deal
let's try the Conchords there was a
hottest thing wrong about follow you
know miss you know who are they fools
yeah they don't really do any deals
anymore we're walking around bro like
hotel anymore right here many many more
what has been the hardest hello to work
with Robertson before I never had to I
work with him actually one time at
Modesto Junior College he was actually a
nice guy he's really cool dude really
cool nothing bad to say I was with him
and that one key day to have an mesquite
we had to eat there was a casino in
Casablanca okay ya know the first time
ever had our coconut shrimp okay another
comment told me brought eat the game
where they have coconut shrimp so I go
over there at the feature that with
Craig Robinson and the headliner was
them dude I never met before
the coconut shrimp bro I forgot bap
you know when you're a kid and you you
want to eat something with the tiny No
so you finally get a chance to eat the
whole thing right that's why I went with
a coconut shrimp before the show like if
they bring more reward
bring me the shrimp boat now you could
do the voice now you can do some bubble
tea I'll get you for the food I put a
shoe that my walkie only there that's
what Joe did a worker you knees you will
get a green pork burrito it's ridiculous
that they got rid of food because they
had like four more hours of night when
they got rid like they within the menu
at like nine and then you guys would you
sure know what started when I ate or
something like that and then you go to
like midnight just to have one guy on
for like like 35 bucks what to pay some
guy you know somebody tell you a
Punisher in the show bro a Punisher man
okay I guess there's a Polish over 25
and the weasel I don't know what's up
fool podcast so what you been working
with big boy oh yeah I'm we're gonna do
a we do should I do shows with him once
in while we're gonna do a big show in
Long Beach with my cap stacks are gonna
be on that show - well days that March
29th so that'll be a big show IV I think
it's the Long Beach theater herbs yeah
because exactly cuz of my chefs FC but
yeah big boys a cool guy we try to do
shows with him once in a while and he's
just uh you know we do some improv here
and there so you know it's always fun to
do those shows you know Blake huh yeah
yeah he's out there you know hustling
and grinding yeah to do the head thing
too
I haven't seen that in a while but I do
another hand comic okay hey hands off
hands off hands off no but I haven't
seen them do that I think a lot of
comics yeah yeah so that needs to be a
Def Jam did it will bring a bag bro
reasonably with short arms blower legs
bro doing legs yeah got him with
wheelchair go though like a family guy
bro
at first RP they made our he made up a
major major like the rudder of their
movie uh-huh and they did [ __ ] you put a
little green screen on his [ __ ]
wheelchair like his brought his buddy
but he wasn't no man had a neighbor bow
yo [ __ ] so don't know bro that was the
first time I ever did good low it don't
you hate it when you're doing the what's
up fool podcast and Rodrigo doing Joey's
Diaz [ __ ] voice for no
[ __ ] reasons come on Chris Rock
doing my karma - no Gabriel si was
begging to be in the Oscars begging bro
to be it like to do baby bro Gabriel
give me did your biggest star you should
be begging begging that means they've
general Jeff Dunham anymore
so a you huh it would be gay bro begging
to be on the Oscars and Chris Rock's
voice yeah all right they stop biggie
okay stop begging Gabriel you can only
hope ghost you're never gonna host the
Oscars come on and take off that fruity
ass [ __ ] shirt yeah I guess did
a bit about Chris Rock claim the king of
the mask is Lopez with the key you know
it's all good you know that video that
one a fluffy did about the Oscar that I
had no idea that joke was so funny man I
had no idea he wanted to do that you
know I had no idea when did this come on
campaign bro oh wow oh yeah I shared it
bro I mean I'm going to yeah I did what
I could you don't only have like hundred
thousand followers well I have a million
I only have two thousand man that's
that's weird their own I did when I
wanted to be in the Eric Andre show I
did my own video too but I said on the
show but you made it you made it
comedian actor Gabriel Iglesias
[Applause]
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the Oscars I am your host -
Gabriel Iglesias
so I got to tell you guys in keeping
with tradition here at the Oscars
here's another Mexican doing a job no
one else wants
[Applause]
and all honestly I really want the job I
just wanted to see if I could pass the
background check no have you about damma
dying good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to the Academy Wow
production values one of those to get on
the [ __ ] to get back on superstore
for them a real name that's that's a
nice little campaign I'm you're gonna
get back on bro when I had to improvise
making fun of what's her name brunette
and I might share with and when I made
for the heard everybody everybody died
sadly were scared to go back over there
across the west and still he's dead not
Felipe yeah my stand-in for the super
stories are stand-in for the guy in the
wheelchair oh yes we are the same skin
tone okay so you could be the hand
you'll probably be the stand-in for
Howie Mandel oh my god I don't know
what's worse fluffy and the Oscars or
Ernie did knob low energies thing is a
worse two references yeah did you see me
no but I've heard too proud to be
American wow this is tough
these are to represent thing I was gonna
[ __ ] here today Motown and more and
[ __ ] Ernie G I don't know man I'm just
trying to [ __ ] college chicks I'm a
motivational speaker bro yes you're not
doing comedy anymore bro we're not doing
comedy more so why aren't doing shampoo
in the show he was up everyone guessed
well there's
and then that one comedian from Houston
who no but number two the keep the old
do Taylor funny
what stuff will you add this coming up
yeah I got um this weekend I'm gonna I'm
gonna be working at the Laugh Factory on
Friday in Long Beach Saturday at the
Ventura Harbor comedy club and then I
got that big show on the 29th at the
Long Beach theater with Big Boi and Mike
Epps and did Portland right did that
[ __ ] I do i do Harvey's when I can
harvest a car SIA what I took money with
me yeah bro I'm sorry what you're in a
new duo now oh yeah now your grill [ __ ]
I love it yeah me too [ __ ] no that's
not gonna agree with neighbor hadn't
lost bookies no man yeah go like they
hang out with the waste I'll dig you
under the the club I've seen I've seen
the underground stuff before not this
time but yeah did you meet the owner Deb
no life no no the owner the owner is
still Barry he owns the Bill Murray :
I don't know Barry right yeah you do
stay in the Condor the no no no more
condo because he he doesn't he doesn't
uh he retired he lives in Palm Springs
alright so he has other people in this
put you in a hotel now but before you'd
had to stay in the competition I have
yes you gotta find you you [ __ ]
figure out as soon as you go to the
airport yep
there's one time one time it was snowing
that was the [ __ ] pain in the ass Oh
so you have to catch the train and way
for me to pick you up it'll drive you to
the Columbia to walk to the club we we
got we got a cab all the nights I took
jackass a Dorian one time Jeff jr. Jack
Jr yeah we didn't sleep in the same bed
damaged [ __ ] so that's always a fun show
bro I was I wasn't a comedy condo and
the last night dude I suppose I suppose
affair enjoying every night but this
time I threw the joint down and
everybody hates some leads
there was people deliveries downstairs
and I remember looking down and the
whole time I thought it was a cherry
like oh [ __ ]
but I still want to sleep but at night I
was thinking then I rammed AK I lit the
whole condo fire and they were no they
don't want to pay me and I was done in
the morning with a coke can
that was stuffed into me in the bottom I
can fireball
I spent Thanksgiving I did things give
you a weekend weekend okay and um
Barry's house were riding to work right
he's next door neighbor that's been
Thanksgiving dinner at their [ __ ]
house that's cool with the whole [ __ ]
family dog they fed you good though they
fairly good but it was weird like like
his older brother mm-hmm like hey like
the mob brought up something about the
brother like winking a lot and then like
I don't know maybe I got too personal
for you and I called somebody at our
table Udo cutting somebody of us by a
stuttering Dame but he don't stutter no
more yeah but that trigger him to
stutter cause he pissed them off or
heard him say guy he got the moving
iPhone I felt bad for the mom said
remember Tom you had that clicking
tongue you know I never did that before
they they know that's when he came out
he got mad well yeah there it is yeah
please well this [ __ ] didn't
give me or no I had to UM I got the bus
Wow over there every day and every day
after the show already before before
over yeah yeah they always have a bus
not that far from there okay we'll catch
it in a bowl mm-hmm and then get in the
bus and take all the way they wants to
do the show and that would run brought
to the bus stop the bus the bus the last
buzz at that midnight so the left will
cut 1115 Wow the Charles Wright food
that's right that's right for the food
but there are some new ownership now
it's it's not bad as they actually treat
about it um some some guy named Jeff
Jeff's a good guy
Jessica Pat Wilson I
one time I did University of Oregon
State back in the days how about China
Lake no no Sharon lay with the worst guy
ever bro did you ever do a show for a
Pierre Pierre he never paid no yeah I
got lucky I never do a show but I heard
stories we shoot at the bottom she said
oh yeah man getting robbed by Pierre
it's a black comedian way of right a
pass right a passage yeah he ripped off
so many people I heard me at the airport
go ahead like you're gonna get on the
plane and I'll meet you there with the
money with the money and you just want
to show up the good ol days I'm still
rocking over there with that but look at
that Christopher Lloyd's let me wear
this jacket one time and it's mine now
it's such a good jacket so your soul
mate him Toby rotating bubbles Brown
whenever we can get the road I know we
get damn used to be over here right yeah
dad
damn works whenever George Lopez over
there or or any East Coast car anyways
close come and I remember him yeah dance
company works with us we run into him
when we were doing the Wilbur theater
and opening up for Advance Jobrani nice
supposed a brooch we're coming to the
spot yeah come here especially we did
the casino man
but I'm such a mess
he's a married man right yeah he's good
he turned down the hotel he's like I'll
just drive back there's like an hour and
a half let's go away from Boston he's a
good dude man I remember damn good
people man she still does the military
gates once a year but not for now that's
right he's to do Millett military stuff
yeah that's cool man should watch out
for where is he from again Minneapolis
okay so when you when you do house of
comedy whatever out there you good hope
either we're doing know we're doing a
theater and winning you back and I seen
you advertising before you're in Vegas
too sometimes a treasure right Treasure
Island is there how'd it go joy
tremendous you were due laughs in New
Mexico you know what I've never done
that but check this out I'm actually
doing a club out there called the comedy
vault for the first time in May it just
opens so I'll let you know how that goes
dududu strip out like well of course
everybody goes through this we're like
like you've been doing coming for a long
time you see these comedians they were
put to stay [ __ ] right but I
guess now I know why now before I
thought just because I just give you the
hater you don't want to book me but I
realized that he just here's a rapport
with him I'm not paying him right I
never did I never he's heard stories
about laughs it closed down obviously I
never did that that's me you don't want
to be there bro I heard that we had a
big goes down anyway so that was the
greenroom where the manager and some of
the waste have lived there too is that
right no the [ __ ] the condo Wow so
you're showering Boyko into the shower
and one of the way she was taking a dump
Wow that's yeah won't you be a wish to
live in a condo I mean the every
headliner he'll try to pick up on you
every week
everybody everybody you guys see the ass
with underwear ancient box Salazar Wow
check it out
the real Slim Shady Wow that's right
yeah I think so
we we did run into him I did a Latin
Kings comedy event in 2015 we ran into
him as last time I saw somebody told me
you were yelling oh yeah Latin Kings of
Comedy over lowering okay we have a
valuable [ __ ] this Franklin no so check
us out we're if we're in Chicago we're
doing Italy Gomez told you so just to
get a belly the greenroom tell you some
tell me some [ __ ] tease me here we go
man Willie I said the Latin Kings are in
the house yeah and I didn't know I did
not know that Latin Kings was a big
[ __ ] game I grew up in Ohio and I
know I didn't know that it's a Midway
the Midwest thing New York City though
yeah not in 2008 you do not know but
they were cooking cobras the beginning
okay yeah well I said instead of saying
Latin Kings of Comedy
I was already had some pops in me anyway
all right some yo that out to a BA and
[ __ ] Michael Caine is like Eve what
the mention like yo Mikey yo Mikey I may
or Chicago he said Mikey was a little
bit no can't you can't say that here
please don't you can't say that I'm like
why he's on then he broke it down
I want to tell you getting Kings lanky
the comedy stop jeez
[Laughter]
we try to do tour dates when we can but
you know Paul's busy Paul's doing his
own thing so once in a while get the
fellas together is usually me him and
Joey once in a while once a my hook
throw gene and gene on the show to G in
his hat bro gene and his hat no ever
happened they drop on her later anyway I
said that you won't pop oh never throw
up bro I'm off of the jury finish a
whole bottle at the club member a
Chardonnay Chardonnay when he does drink
Chardonnay like in his coffee mug he
does all day they put it they wouldn't
go find a kid's zip Cup I get for a
kid's drink somewhere he took off with a
drink they taste like dinosaurs and
Stegosaurus and a full of vodka and or
he goes he's gonna make you a drink
you know she's filling up with vodka
just give me a cranberry juice on the
side no we got to go television I had
four hairs left
I had a cutter I had to cut him I was
like many times he and he's from the
Central Valley - he's from receiver -
Larry this frontal area
[Laughter]
[ __ ] now well you guys just kept me
Mexican god damn it I am Mexican
no mommy I thought lose in North America
no you're a bourbon Hey nothing
of course that I haven't done in a long
time
yeah but I've done it before it's a fun
room that's a fun yeah so I'm just
trying to you know just grind do some
teeth I haven't done Tommy to use a
minute but I would did it all the time
when I first started just go back over
there bro I have trouble paying YouTube
man I love my wife man I love my first
wife - that's why she works here yeah
people sounds a little bit like Towelie
good to see you Tommy good to see Tommy
- so cool that that are we ready -
Christopher Titus mm-hmm at the Empire
airplane there now and I stop by and say
Christopher Titus out or generally
Timothy Tommy T he would say that he
helped you write your second special he
also killed John Fox - fireman but
[ __ ] you're digging into crates no
big sigh John yeah Bernal with Mike
Bernal those who the boy does that's my
dude that's where I did a lot of my
shows there and then the San Francisco
punchline to a podcast or anything no no
I used to have him back in the days but
you never should have kept the gory bro
so I was part of that
that toad hoc network thing that went
under
hey Joey no I forgot that a studio and
everybody asked people at the park isn't
in the [ __ ] Club
they're asking I know they are asked to
do a parker back then but we're like
lame I said now but I remember you made
the eggs no put up the best choice but
to do a live podcast you wasn't named
the one that was like set up like a show
yeah I got a talk-show who's not a comic
[Music]
he's like very put together very like
slick just we had we had a podcast from
ah who me and Ida Rodriguez my co-host
about that let's call Manny to the max
know about that remember that all wrong
us in many and more how many a more
populist it all wrong they brought
wouldn't you an Edith day T to the Barca
Union yeah no MIT so you remember the
set up at the head up man yeah yeah we
were there for almost a year I told you
had your own podcast I think it's why
did they leave it was two thousand two
thousand eleven to twelve yeah he didn't
want to take it somewhere else the
network like marketing they had a lot of
shows you know what they were starting
to do too they wanted to start charging
us for our airtime oh I was already
making the drive cuz I was living in
Playa del Rey at the time I didn't want
to drive all the way out there and then
I had to pay I was like no I'm good yo
son I have a son he's 13 now yeah
[Music]
no she's pretty good kid my son when he
was four
I got an Apsara Lindbergh baby killer
dog I'm not gonna pick him up Chile will
you know Ordonez
it's the best it will eat initiate and
look to and not said a word he probably
would his body about the very short
about two hands we say no [ __ ] hairy
ass [ __ ] and we never notice the you
know I think I feel like Luke torrid
look towards cousin do a lot of person
is just like you Horace is right you
ever hear him do Paul Rodriguez
introducing other comedians like he does
the point
yeah everything to a tee and he does D
militant he's the real deal very happy
shaking in his boots a very under a very
sensitive towards very underrated very
underrated the fourth of B with prior
game Lou Torres really yeah he's badass
you know you know yeah what happened
holding back you keep a real brother you
don't wear hats
I try to nice little shaped and sorry
were you scared like when you took it
all up oh yeah like what is the final
shape of my head like
I was scared we have to go bottoms wear
headphones bro and I right you know I
just on the bus for no reason sometimes
I'm not under 115 augmentis for no
reason you like that I knew you would
get that premise dawg good luck hey
Manny sometimes I'm on the sometimes I'm
on the bus and I ride I'm like sometimes
I'm on the bus and we're taking him
dropping him off I'm waiting at the red
light and he goes oh this one you can
turn left before anyone else cuz you'll
have an arrow and you can at this
intersection I said yeah that's pretty
much around the country you can turn
love ya then he was like all insulted
because what's our food this week I'm in
Miami at the Miami improv wash it to
attend San Angelo Texas March 15 at the
San Angelo apiaceae PAC Center Wichita
Kansas March 16 at all from theater
grant judge in Colorado monitored to a
velocity the auditing tenses at the
improv was Instagram it's Manny ma and
NY the number two th e ma X Manning to
the max what's up full same thing with
Twitter and Facebook yeah twitter is at
Manny Maldonado and same thing on
Facebook just manny mota
what's a raider game bro yo bro that
[ __ ] counting was killing me the
caching [ __ ] left me your dog
you know what's crazy bro right by the
cannon it was crazy that we do the
podcast every Wednesday mm-hmm
the first way that we go outside we
don't see Brody Stephens car reading his
baseball cards we play that through our
pocket right it was that two o'clock
yeah we ran it home last week do we see
enough for every Wednesday for the last
year mm-hmm last three last three years
every time we see one throw it up
baseball cards Wow play baseball triple
a fool a 1 April life